welcome to this video i am vox Dei the
voice of God I think Boris Mary asin
okay don't know the guy from Ukraine
maybe I should take if he gives me this
opportunity c6 it's not happening that
off mostly play with the c5 yeah no I
think this is just a fairly comfortable
position out of the green felt with just
white having the somewhat better central
control okay yeah I want to have before
after a 4b for now just a good good
control I would like to keep this Bishop
on g4 on the board I know it's taking it
I would have tried to rookie 195 not
exchanging more pieces this type of
position here is certainly am slightly
more comfortable for white but black is
extremely solid so it's nothing that
white can be particularly proud of
interesting want to go e 5 on I don't
don't really know what this move is
doing
game
really not sure Knight g4 looks like a
bit like I know yeah it's like just
kicking the ball and front of the goal
and then soccer or football and hoping
that somebody is there but it looks like
a single single single player standing
there doing not much okay um Knight to
c3 again so let's let's protect this the
reason why why it is slightly better
here and I only really mean very
slightly is that black has no no palm
brakes whatsoever he has no active idea
what I can play b4 b5 maybe on do
something based on the bishop again is
doing that what is the point really
don't know always irritates me because
like stuff that I don't understand okay
I don't want to exchange that much but
at least this way cakes and cupcakes is
again intending to take on g4 and then
b4 b5 maybe
yeah now I'm just threatening to okay
threatening to take and play rook g5
winning this porn was my intended
sentence and maybe he gets some
counterclaim maybe he gets some counter
play in the in the center but still it's
maybe possible rook t5 rookie aid based
on the somewhat misplaced rook on g4
maybe the term seems though that he
didn't intend this
okay yeah they couldn't plate quicken
and King there why am yeah I don't know
mmm it's efore move or am I just
weakening myself
not sure about it yeah probably not a
good idea maybe I can actually play king
here Andrew H 1 attending root g5 and
eh5 can be a move at at some point h5 g5
looks strange for me but maybe I'm with
the right combination of moves that can
be a can be an idea exactly now I could
play with g5 maybe it maybe do it and
not spend so much time on this takes H
takes g5 is a check of also okay I
cannot take c5 of this name because of
this this pin
okay I need to increase the speed habit
my ideas at c d e 4 and then h5 maybe
maybe I'm making a big mistake here
because the g porn can be very very
quick but now ok I need to play a move
at some point Wow yeah this is actually
what I had what I had feared that he
would just move away the king
CDE form and maybe yeah but it's not
it's not really really convincing hg I'm
not I'm not threatening anything very
quickly at least he cannot move the deep
on that's a good thing because of the
check made on on H aid if he goes
Queenie 7 I mean okay here I'm just
trying to play for an endgame d3i just a
group do you want at the end gay masseur
of course clearly better yes that such
that she can do how to do this now rook
d1 maybe time morning maybe I should go
here and then Quincy 7
yeah you five the queen is boxed in yo26
is not any good I can go here though and
10 the e6 um II 627 and that cake oh now
I can take with the corner this is
threatening f7 with with disaster Queen
g7 though i think was also also good
check we're not winning here check check
check check check no okay it's still
winning good No aah what what the heck
and I believe this guy game drawn ah ah
what a game every this is the kind of
way this guy's gonna shines right with
with b3 up with a forehead is this kind
of stuff the whole game is a total
one-way street okay come on ah anyway
yeah of course I must just win it with
the checkmate I didn't see the check
mate check Queen f6 is made hmm yeah you
sort of want to give checks okay bye
jess is of course gently winning check
it's nothing that
any problem i just need to play route da
this is also winning of course I just
here he only hits this 84 and this one
was just bad bad bullet play order by me
you just need to play a four to make
sure that this is not happening but okay
here the check in at the ante again
suppose again winning the white but
Chang of course just typical bullets
bullets stuff yeah it was a somewhat
weird way in the in the middle game this
is Nyjah foremost really strange jam and
this isn't in fact questionable if this
is any good because my look is misplaced
but walking King age 7 and so on a
certainly not great yeah this was
interesting I don't know Quincy 1c7 s is
probably right and here I think why
should be very much in very much ahead
with the active cool yay around here the
computers is giving why the very
substantial edge and now he 6 is just
really flat winning yeah hmm stupid but
okay it was very little touch that she
was always always a wind check when you
need to avoid this this simple trick
here with with a form okay thanks for
watching